carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos a este nuevo número de
carrusel de las artes muy contentos que
estén en nuestra sintonía y hoy en
nuestro programa vamos a explorar un
género artístico y dramático del que se
habla poco y sin embargo tiene una
historia que remonta el siglo 19 se
trata del burlesque y con nosotros soy
una artista mexicana de ese género
burlesque teresa rubo que está hoy con
nosotros en nuestros estudios teresa
muchísimas gracias por estar aquí el
carrusel de las artes muchísimas gracias
a ustedes por invitarme y bueno ya mismo
vamos a hablar de eso a lo que tú te
dedicas el burlesque aquí en carrusel de
las artes
[Música]
con nosotros soy un artista productora y
performer teresa lugo teresa tú naciste
en veracruz en méxico y de te dedicas
aquí en parís al burlesque que es una
arte esférica que mezcla canto baile
humor erotismo pero tú cómo lo definiría
yo lo definiría como el arte del
erotismo
aunque se mezclan diferentes disciplinas
y hay también hay comedia hay humor hay
baile
hay varias cosas esa es la parte rica
que a mí me gusta el cabaret burlesque
que todo puede entrar y ahora cómo
llegaste tú al burlesque o como el
burlesque des llegó a ti porque tú
vienes del teatro si yo vengo del teatro
y de méjico yo comencé en méjico y
conozco el burlesque gracias a una
mexicana que tenía más de 30 años
viviendo aquí en parís y que va a méxico
a dar clases de cabaret burlesque es así
como lo conozco quedó enamorada y
después decidió venir a parís para
conocer exactamente de qué me estaban
hablando y como como uno se prepara para
ser artista de burlas urges es bastante
difícil porque no hay una escuela
institucional o sea
podríamos decir que no es un arte serio
no es un arte que esté validado por las
artes no entonces tú te formas a manera
de un poco empíricamente pero si hay
maestros que pueden darte clases hay
artistas de los cuales pueden darte una
inspiración para poder entender un poco
los códigos que maneja este arte y ahora
como te lo decías como mezcla canto y
baile tienes que ser buen bailarín o el
cantante buen humorista aunque sí y no
al mismo tiempo porque yo no soy
bailarina pero bailo es muy gracioso
porque lo principal es hacer una buena
interpretación no el baile ahora las que
son bailarinas se ven divinas entonces o
las que cantan se ven muy bien entonces
esa es la parte rica de este género
porque todo es válido y pero sin embargo
como yo no soy bailarina tengo que
entrenarme mucho en el baile aunque no
sea el objetivo de este género y ahora
aquí en parís porque tú trabajas aquí en
parís hay mucha tradición de cabaret hay
acá bares que datan de la belle epoque
de principios del siglo 20 que todavía
incluso están en funcionamiento el
moulin junto al molino rojo o el lido
cuál es la diferencia entre cabaret y
cabaret burlesque incluso tú hablabas
hace un segundo de cabaret burlesque si
son son los códigos es decir en el
moulin rouge o en el libro tú puedes ver
las mujeres que ya están desnudas ok
bueno semidesnudas y en el cabaret
burlesque tú vas a descubrir el arte de
ser de quitarse a la rubia el desnudarse
desde desnudarse entonces no es lo mismo
los códigos igual antes en la época
habían leyes donde donde no permitían el
desnudo es así como surge este arte y
ahora en el burlesque puedes llegar al
desnudo porque muchas veces los números
que pueden ser una canción
'the desde desnudas pero no llegas al
desnudo completo no porque es otro de
los códigos nunca vas a estar desnuda
porque entonces ya no es por la scj así
que hay que cuidar una estética una
cierta estética lo más desnudo que tú
puedes quedar es con pezoneras y con una
no sé cómo se dice en español con un
sexo
cubre a un hombre de sexo un cubre sexo
exactamente y cuéntanos por qué nos
hablaba bueno tú vienes del teatro como
lo decíamos que te formaste con esta
artista mexicana que ya estaba acá pero
también hay un
entrenamiento justamente al desnudo o
hacia el desnudo como cómo se aprende
toma tiempo porque imagino que hay que
aprender a ser
fuerte en la escena o segura de tu
sensualidad
es es un trabajo largo no es un trabajo
fácil
para mí fue descubrirlo ni siquiera me
plantea la pregunta es que estoy desnuda
en el escenario mis amigos me preguntan
y walter es es que cómo le haces digo yo
no me siento jamás desnuda ahora cada
quien es diferente y ahora como maestra
lo que siempre hago es
que las chicas descubran el desnudo a
partir del juego dramático ese es como
mi parte fuerte porque vienen mis bases
del teatro y es ahí donde enseñó que a
partir del juego podemos desnudarnos sin
sentirnos culpables y al mismo tiempo tú
te apropias de tu propio cuerpo y ese
aprender la desinhibición que se
necesita para estar desnuda en la seno
casi desnuda la escena es difícil toma
tiempo como lo ves tú cómo fue tu
proceso y cómo es el proceso con las
chicas a las que tú le das clase de
burlesque y bueno en principio pues
tomar clases no y al mismo tiempo como
regularmente las clases son con puras
chicas se hace un círculo femenino donde
todas nos apoyamos y donde todas nos
sentimos en confianza y es ahí donde
viene esta liberación de poder mostrar
nuestro cuerpo tal y como es porque una
de las cosas que se distingue del
cabaret burlesque y como hace rato que
me lo preguntaban
el music-hall no al moulin rouge es que
en este arte se aceptan todo tipo de
cuerpos aquí no hay estereotipos de
belleza todas y todos pueden hacer
burlesque todas todas son bellas todos
los cuerpos son bellos entonces yo creo
que a partir de una de estas clases de
burlesque donde te enseñan a jugar con
personajes con ciertos personajes tu
puedes jugar a liberarte de ciertos
tabúes que la misma sociedad de impuesto
a las mujeres por ejemplo tienes algún
tabú el del que te has liberado tú mismo
indie que me haya liberado yo misma es
de poder caminar en la calle de la forma
que yo quiera vestirme yo creo que es
uno de los más grandes tabúes que he
podido quitar a partir de que hago
burlesque sentirme segura de mí misma de
apropiarme de mi cuerpo de lo que soy
porque antes me sentía como sí
tengo ciertos estándares de cuerpo que
pueden provocar a los hombres y evitaba
ponerme las cosas que a mí me gustaban
porque decía es que voy a provocar no es
que vamos a provocar es que la sociedad
tiene que
reeducarse a mirar con otros ojos no no
son las mujeres todo el tiempo las
culpables de cómo se visten para asia la
provocación del hombre o de insultos yo
creo que cuando tú tomas clases de
burlesque tienes este poder que te dice
no en mi cuerpo es sagrado este es mi
cuerpo yo lo protejo y no tengo por qué
ocultarlo de nadie y ahora que tú hablas
justamente de esas ideas que pueden
tener que puede tener la sociedad que
pueden tener las mismas mujeres con
respecto a su cuerpo o la mirada de los
hombres como en este tipo de cabaret
burlesque hay justamente ese desnudo te
han acusado de pornografía de vulgaridad
cuáles son las críticas que puedes
recibir en particular yo no
en realidad no sé por qué una vez
alguien me lo dijo es que es por la
forma en que tú manejas tu trabajo no
cuidamos también mucho lo digo cuidamos
porque hay otras colegas con las cual
concuerdo cuidamos mucho nuestra imagen
es decir cuidamos el tipo de fotos que
subimos por ejemplo cuando yo comencé en
mexico
yo no me quitaba toda la ropa o sea no
me quitaban no me quedaba en pezoneras
evidentemente que llegó a parís con una
sociedad mucho más abierta me exigí
bueno no me exigían pero si había como
un cierto
estándares de códigos le decían no es
que se tiene que mostrar tiene que haber
personas no entonces ya ok entonces hubo
un hubo un antes y un después para mí a
partir de que yo llegué a parís pude
liberarme si mis fotos son más son más
al descubierto pero para mí siempre hay
una estética siempre hay un personaje
siempre hay una temática siempre hay un
porqué yo voy a subir esa foto
y ahora que hablas de estética tú eres
mexicana como lo decíamos se han
integrado en sus espectáculos tu cultura
mexicana incluso hasta que te has
reapropiado de la figura de la catrina
por ejemplo que es muy importante con el
día de los muertos que algo como
fundamental no de la cultura mexicana
cuéntanos un poco cómo has adaptado esa
cultura y cómo las mostrado aquí en
parís y ahora bueno comencé yo a
apropiarme un poco de mi misma cultura a
raíz de que me sentía muy lejos de mi
país entonces cuál era la mejor forma de
poder sentirse cerca de ellos era partir
de mostrar mi cultura a los otros y yo
creo que cada vez que interpretó un
número donde hay un contenido una
temática mexicana yo me siento como pez
en el agua y me siento como contenta y
orgullosa de poder mostrar mi cultura y
mis orígenes el folklore mexicano es
maravilloso los colores la cultura las
danzas la música
y no sólo antes era mexicana pero ahora
me atraen mucho a la cultura latina no
la música sobre todo
los rituales que se hacen no es muy es
muy grande es muy grande todo este
bagaje que hay de nuestras culturas en
latinoamérica y como he recibido ese
cabaret burlesque a la mexicana aquí en
europa ahí les fue acción les fascina y
bueno bueno hay ciertos clichés
evidentemente les gusta mucho que yo
haga números mexicanos sin embargo lo
que yo siempre trato es de mostrar un
tema no porque yo hay dos tipos de
burlesque el burlesque clásico y el y el
new burlesque el new burlesque siempre
trata de
decir algo y ese es mi parte como actriz
que yo busco todo el tiempo decir algo
no solamente me desnudo te pongo un
ejemplo el número número de la catrina
es un acto que hace una protesta
política es decir hacia los actos de
racismo hacia el contenido hacia todas
es este odio
a los latinoamericanos que ha hecho
donald trump o que hizo durante todo su
periodo de gobernación como presidente
de los eeuu entonces en este acto en
particular me llevó como a la cima
porque no es solo burlesque vamos a
quitarnos la ropa sino dice algo hay un
hay ahí hay algo que dice no algo que se
produce en los otros y bueno he estado
en diferentes partes del mundo y en
todas he visto la misma reacción y eso
como mexicana y como latina me llena de
orgullo porque decir sí o sea no más
fronteras no no más muros no todos somos
seres humanos al final y bueno
justamente ahora que estás hablando de
eso vamos a despedir nuestro programa
con una de tus interpretaciones de la
catrina y de ese mensaje del que nos
hablaba es una interpretación el
festival burlesque de hamburgo te
agradezco muchísimo a ustedes a que
hayan venido hasta nuestros estudios
para hablarnos de ese arte que tiene que
conocerse también en todo el mundo y
pues muchísimas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros gracias a ustedes por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la verdad
curso
[Música]
[Aplausos]